T
ARGLD
DURING THE UEEDO
AS THAT KRB S LEARNES TE
LDT
TH
DO12
BOAND IN AUGUST THEY SEIZED
OTHER  FM TRUMER10
LET'S DISCUSS WITHVI
STE M.OU GE
TEPH TRUMP LAWYER PATOLD THE AR
MEADS A DOBOS WISPAPER S. ACTUAW
THIS IS ALMOST
>> WELHAD -- [
DI
SAY THEO BELIEVE
THAT THERE WERR
CL THAT
IS HOW HE ED.
THHEISALLED TH A
NEWSP CLIPPINGS THE
HITHATWA
TO
SO THE BLWAYS HAVE
TOLD THAT THERE WERE
HE IS RIGHTEOUS T THINK THAT HE
DO
FAGAT MESSAGE RKTET WAS IN THOS.
IT WAS TRUILING . MARK  KNOW.
Y TRUMEM HE SAYSE
ASSIFIED EVERYTHING.
SO IF IT WAS JUST NEWSPAPE
IPWAS ITDECLASSIFIED.
AT IMY
U D PICK
JU MISSED INH SC S AND
ON, WHAT AR THOU?H, IT IS COMPL
ENIRS.ANIL THEHERE.
BELONGS  U B
ERVICETH.
AT I'M VERCONF A ISEO T WAS  THE
AS IN THE
THAT
D LVED AND WHAT , BUT IT IS IMPO
APPEARE THE COMPLETE
>> AND, UME
HUWHAT
AC
CHLE.
HAPPENE T PROBL
COUNTHAPS WE'VE  BEFORE.N'THTEDO
>> WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS, MR. E
STEAN TRUMPNCNG THE OUT
THINK THTO ARMTHG FOR
THE EX OF COD IFLD HAPPE.
YOOW, HEEA
EEPS HE HAS A GROUP ORY, OYAL
EVANND
WILLO ANNGE T WE SITARGS Y OW VL
STEPSAHAENT  TYOU KNOW,
THPRESENIS
A TR LET'S GETIT IS CLEAR.
AND HEL HE
SAYS.
THER
CAMS BAUIS
D IT I
LEADERNG NOWG R
UP, T GO TO ROOM FORIO
RHETORICI HOPE -N'T REALLY
BSAND T E IS TRYING TO DO IS
YING TO SCAR TRYING TO IS TRYIN.
>> A A
JUOO.
THS .NDTEOU
ABOUT THE NEW BOOKM PETER AND S.
THEY SAY THAT MELANI
SLAMS HANDLING OCOVID AT POINT
IR BOOK, YOU'RE
BLOWING THIS, IT IS GOIN BE  N
RI
THEY WRITE THAT  DISMISSED HNDE
MONT OPANDEMIC, DID YOU
OUA MASK, MELANIA TRUMP WAFIRSTO
LE WAND  WING WANOTE WAS WORINT
ABRISL WILL BE FIN AUTG THIS, B
S ANABOUT
D STAFF AND HER
LY WHEN D G  AND OLIVIA, I KNOWE
WERE PEOPLHE WHIAND THE  TP WASE
HONESTLY, IT IG  ACCOUTHAT HED
D OF CY HOMETOWNF PASO  AND THEE
EVERYONE KNED THO
EXHIBITED COMPLETE